all right singer-songwriter Joss Stone
has released her first holiday album I
talked with her about the album her new
Christmas music video and what it's like
being a mom of two check it out
[Music]
Grammy Award winner and two-time Brit
Award winner Joss Stone has gone from
soul singer to Holiday Queen what I've
wanted to do a holiday album for over 10
years now her first holiday album Merry
Christmas love has made its debut I
really feel like this time of year is
very special and it can't be just you
can't just Chuck an album together you
know you need to take it very seriously
and be very careful and it needs to be
magical and the Magic Begins from the
moment you hit play well when you hit
play I will be reading you a little
piece of Twas the Night Before Christmas
just to set the tone
and I hope that if you close your eyes
you can imagine there's snowflakes
falling just outside the window even if
you're in Vegas
[Music]
that's her latest music video What
Christmas Means to Me That Joss Stone
filmed with baby number two on the way I
was like I don't know what's like seven
months pregnant maybe eight I don't know
um but I felt really like oh God I can't
move you know I was in one of those
spaces because it was hard growing
people and then when I did the video
when I actually got to the scenes and
the moment where you get to dance around
with your band members and there was all
the extras there and everyone was
dressed up to the nines like
it was kind of magical and it really
like breathed life into me the timing
for this holiday album just made sense
and now I thought now is the right time
and especially now because I've got kids
it makes it even more the right time
congratulations on your growing family
and I'm sure Mom is your your favorite
job what's it been like to still make
music start your family are they kind of
your inspiration
they offer this one definitely for this
album because this the kind of the magic
and the specialness of Christmas time is
because of children I think for me it is
anyway Merry Christmas love is available
now